PRESIDENT TRUMP HITTING BACK
HARD AGAINST DEMOCRAT JOAQUIN
CASTRO FOR OUTING CAMPAIGN
DONORS.
GOING AFTER THE CONGRESSMAN ON
TWITTER SAYING:
"I DON'T KNOW WHO JOAQUIN CASTRO
IS OTHER THAN THE LESSER BROTHER
OF A FAILED PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE (1%) WHO MAKES A FOOL
OF HIMSELF EVERY TIME HE OPENS
HIS MOUTH.
JOAQUIN IS NOT THE MAN THAT HIS
BROTHER IS, BUT HIS BROTHER,
ACCORDING TO MOST, IS NOT MUCH.
KEEP FIGHTING, JOAQUIN!"
DESPITE THE BACKLASH, CASTRO IS
NOT BACKING DOWN.
>> I DON'T WANT ANYONE HARASSED
OR TARGETED.
>> THEY WILL BE BECAUSE YOU PUT
THEIR NAMES OUT IN PUBLIC.
>> THAT WAS NOT MY INTENTION.
THESE THINGS ARE PUBLIC.
WHEN I WOULD LIKE FOR THEM TO DO
IS THINK TWICE ABOUT SUPPORTING
THE GUY WHO IS FUELING HATE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> Dana: THE CONTROVERSY
RAISING A QUESTION, IS THERE A
DOUBLE STANDARD WHEN IT COMES TO
CLAIMS OF SOCIAL MEDIA BIAS.
CONGRESSMAN CASTRO WAS TWEETING
TO SHAME TRUMP SUPPORTERS,
MITCH McCONNELL'S CAMPAIGN GOT
LOCKED OUT OF TWITTER AFTER
POSTING A VIDEO SHOWING
PROTESTERS MAKING THREATS
OUTSIDE OF HIS HOME.
BEFORE THE ACCOUNT WAS RESTORED,
McCONNELL'S CAMPAIGN MANAGER
SANG TWITTER WILL ALLOW THE
WORDS OF MASSACRE MR. TRAN
NATIONALLY
>> Greg: THE INTERESTING THING
FROM CASTRO WAS WHEN HE SAID I
HAD NO INTENTION BUT MAYBE
PEOPLE WILL THINK TWICE.
WHAT HE'S SAYING THIS COULD
HAPPEN TO YOU.
MY HANDS AREN'T ON THIS.
I'VE NOTHING TO DO WITH IT BUT
IF YOU WANT TO THINK TWICE.
IT'S SINISTER STUFF.
TERTIARY THUGGERY.
HE WANTS PEOPLE TO DO THE DIRTY
WORK WHILE HE IS THE LOGISTICS
GUY.
HE WRITES THE ADDRESSES DOWN ON
A PIECE OF PAPER AND SLIPS IT TO
THE GUY.
THIS GUY MEETS AN ACCIDENT, AND
NOTHING TO DO WITH ME.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE EXPANDING
TARGET OF DEMONIZATION.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO GO AFTER
TRUMP.
YOU HAVE TO GO AFTER HIS TEAM,
THE SUPPORTERS, THE VOTERS, AND
ANYONE NOT PART OF THE
RESISTANCE, ANYONE WHO BREATHES
THE SAME AIR AS TRUMP IS
VULNERABLE AND THAT INCLUDES
OBVIOUSLY DEMOCRATS BECAUSE WE
ALL SHARE THE SAME OXYGEN.
I POSED THE QUESTION TO
LIBERALS, DO YOU WANT TO BE PART
OF A MOVEMENT THAT SEEKS TO DOXX
OR PUNISH PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY
DISAGREE POLITICALLY?
THAT GOES NOWHERE GOOD.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO HAVE LEFT?
FAR LEFT ACTIVISTS RUNNING YOUR
BUSINESS IS?
YOU WOULD ONLY HAVE ONE
ICE CREAM FACTORY IN VERMONT.
>> Donna: A LOT OF LIBERALS
WHO OWN A LOT OF REAL ESTATE.
I GUESS I'M THE DESIGNATED
LIBERAL.
>> Greg: I WAS TALKING TO DAN.
YOU KNOW HE'S A LEFTY.
>> Dan: BIG TIME.
>> Donna: AS YOU KNOW, I DON'T
BELIEVE IN POINTING OUT PEOPLE
WHO ARE OUT THERE SUPPORTING ANY
CANDIDATE BUT THIS INFORMATION
IS PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
IT'S PUBLICLY AVAILABLE ON THE
WEBSITE, THE FTC REPORT IS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
I FOUND OUT WHO GAVE TO THE
GOVERNOR, WHO DIDN'T.
>> Dana: I LIKE HOW YOU BRING
PROPS.
>> Greg: A LOT OF THINGS ARE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE BUT WHEN A
CONGRESSMAN PUTS IT OUT TO HIS
FOLLOWERS ON TWITTER.
>> Donna: DONALD TRUMP IS THE
BIGGEST TWITTER YOU KNOW WHAT IN
THE WHOLE WIDE WORLD.
>> Greg: SUCCESS STORY?
IS THAT YOU KNOW WHAT?
>> Donna: HE PUSHES BUTTONS
LIKE NO ONE ELSE.
THIS IS NOT DOXXING.
>> Dan: GIVE OUT THE NAME OF
THE BUSINESS.
>> Donna: I THINK HIS
INTENTION WAS TO EXPOSE THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO'D GIVEN TO THE
PRESIDENT UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
SOME OF THESE INDIVIDUALS ALSO
GAVE TO THE CONGRESSMAN.
>> Dana: CAN WE HEAR FROM ONE
OF THOSE PEOPLE ON THE LIST.
HE CAME ON TELEVISION TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
>> BEING OUTED AS A COUNTRY.
IT WASN'T A PROBLEM BUT TYING ME
TO THE HORRIFIC TRAGEDY IN
EL PASO WAS GALLING.
IN AMERICA WE HAVE A RIGHT TO
FREE SPEECH AND I AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT SUPPORT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE ARE NOT
GOING TO BE CALLED RACIST AND
THE OTHER SLURS WITHOUT FIGHTING
BACK.
>> Dana: DAN.
>> Dan: DONNA, I DISAGREE.
TAKE THE LOSS ON THIS AT AND
MADE IT WAS DUMB.
THE DUMB TEST IS WHAT YOU DO
THIS TO YOUR OPPONENT.
THE ANSWER IS NEVER.
IF SOMETHING HAPPENED TO THAT
PERSON OR THEIR KIDS BECOME SOME
MANIAC FOUND SOME INSPIRATION IN
IT AND DECIDED TO TARGET THAT
PERSON.
ONE MORE POINT, THIS PUBLIC
NONSENSE, IT'S PUBLIC.
SO IS MY WEBSITE BUT I SPENT A
LOT OF MONEY TO ADVERTISE ON MY
WEBSITE TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
FIND.
PUTTING IT ON YOUR TWITTER
ACCOUNT WITH PEOPLE'S NAMES AND
BUSINESSES AND SAY IT'S PUBLIC,
IT IS THE LAMEST EXCUSE EVER.
YOU'RE MAKING PEOPLE EASIER TO
FIND.
>> Dana: I THINK THERE WILL BE
MORE OF THIS.
JULIAN CASTRO TWEETED SAID
JOAQUIN AND I WILL KEEP
FIGHTING.
WILL FIGHT AGAINST YOUR HATE,
CORRUPTION, AND WE WILL WIN.
I THINK CASTRO DOING THAT WILL
ENCOURAGE OTHERS TO DO IT
BECAUSE YOU COULD FIND IT.
>> Lawrence: 100%.
HERE IS THE BOTTOM LINE.
HATE HAS BEEN ASSOCIATED WITH
CONSERVATIVES.
IF YOU'RE REPUBLICAN,
CONSERVATIVE, AND YOU THINK
ABOUT THE BUSINESS, WHAT ABOUT
THE LOCAL LEVEL?
AVERAGE AMERICANS.
THE UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS IS GOING
THROUGH THIS.
THE INCOMING FRESHMAN CLASS ARE
EXPERIENCING DOXXING.
THEY ARE GOING TO JOIN A
CONSERVATIVE GROUP, THEIR
INFORMATION IS PUBLIC.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR THE
STATE OF TEXAS HAS BEEN ASKED TO
GET INVOLVED BY THE UNIVERSITY
OF TEXAS BECAUSE THIS IS
HAPPENING.
THESE WERE HIGH SCHOOLERS.
THEY ARE KIDS.
JUST BECAUSE THEY WANT TO JOIN A
CONSERVATIVE GROUP THEY ARE
BEING TARGETED.
IT'S NONSENSE.
I THINK DEMOCRATS COZY UP TO
THESE TYPES OF PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHY WHEN IT COMES TO
ANTIFA, THEY WON'T DO IT.
THE POLITICIANS WILL DO IT.
THEY SAY THEY ARE HATEFUL
PEOPLE.
WHEN HATE BECOME SYNONYMOUS IN
THEIR EYES OF CONSERVATIVES AND
REPUBLICANS, THAT BECOMES A BIG
PROBLEM.
>> Donna: WHAT ABOUT WHAT WE
PRACTICE TODAY WHEN WE DISLIKE
WITH THE OTHER SIDE IS DOING.
THERE'S A BIGGER ISSUE HERE.
THE BIGGER ISSUE IS SHOULD WE
USE SOCIAL MEDIA TO PROMOTE AND
HIGHLIGHT AND AMPLIFY HATE?
I SAID THE OTHER DAY WHEN WE --
WHEN THIS FIRST CAME OUT, THAT I
WOULD NOT HAVE DONE IT BECAUSE I
HAVE BEEN A VICTIM, INCLUDING
FROM SOMEBODY AT THE VERY TOP OF
OUR FOOD CHAIN, USING
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS, CALLING
ME OUT ON FALSE PRETENSES AND I
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE WHEN PEOPLE
COME AFTER YOU.
I'M NOT FOR THIS BUT WHAT I'M
SAYING IS THIS INFORMATION IS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
WHAT THE CONGRESSMAN DID I
BELIEVE HAS STARTED A NONSENSE
CONVERSATION OVER MEDIA
PLATFORMS AND HOW THEY'RE BEING
WEAPONIZE.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN IT AND I
DON'T BELIEVE THIS IS JUST
ANOTHER CASE OF A CONGRESSMAN
TRYING TO GET ATTENTION.
THIS WAS A STUPID IDEA IN A WEEK
WHEN WE ARE TRYING TO FOCUS ON
THE HEALING OF OUR COUNTRY.
>> Greg: THE POINT YOU MAKE IS
TRUE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO MAKE THIS WEEK
ANY WORSE THAN IT IS.
PEOPLE SHOULD WAKE UP IN THE
MORNING AND GO OKAY, IS WHAT I
AM ABOUT TO DO GOING TO MAKE IT
BETTER OR WORSE?
UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T DO THAT.
I DO THINK -- I WILL JUST STOP.
I SHOULD TAKE MY OWN ADVICE.
>> Dan: A LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE